"
7:00 A.M., FOX NATION.
SO COMMONLY A BARELY NOTICE IT,
BUT THE BIGGEST COMPANIES IN THE
COUNTRY DISCRIMINATE OPENLY
AGAINST THEIR EMPLOYEES ON THE
BASIS OF SKIN COLOR.
IT'S EVERYWHERE, IT'S ILLEGAL.
WHAT IS CHANGING IS THAT SOME OF
THE EMPLOYEES ARE FIGHTING BACK
AND A DECADE AT AMEX UNTIL HE
WAS FIRED IN 2020, JUST FIRED A
CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT AGAINST THE
COMPANY AND SAYS THAT
AMERICAN EXPRESS GAVE
PREFERENTIAL TREATMENT FOR BEING
BLACK AND UNAMBIGUOUSLY SIGNALED
TO WHITE EMPLOYEES THAT THE RACE
WAS AN IMPEDIMENT TO GETTING
AHEAD IN THE COMPANY.
AGAIN, THAT IS HAPPENING
EVERYWHERE, AND HERE'S SOMEONE
WHO IS TAKING IT TO COURT.
DAVID TOROK IS THE MAN IN THIS
CASE AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
SO I'M NOT A LAWYER, BUT IT DOES
SEEM THAT THIS IS UNAMBIGUOUSLY
ILLEGAL, CORRECT?
>> ABSOLUTELY, TUCKER, IT IS
UNLAWFUL.
IT HAS BEEN ILLEGAL SINCE AT
LEAST THE 1960s SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT,
BUT THE REASON THAT THIS IS
HAPPENING IS BECAUSE BACK IN THE
SUMMER OF FLOYD IN 2020, A LOT
OF THE CORPORATION SAW THAT WITH
THE BLM WRITERS ALLOWED TO BURN
DOWN ENTIRE CITIES WITH
ABSOLUTELY ZERO CONSEQUENCES
BECAUSE IT WAS IN THE NAME OF
SOCIAL JUSTICE.
SO WHY WOULDN'T THE COMPANY IS
BEING EMBOLDENED TO TREAT THEIR
WHITE EMPLOYEES LIKE
SECOND-CLASS CITIZENS AND
VIOLATE THEM ON THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS IN
THIS COUNTRY WHEN YOU SEE THIS
PRECEDENT THAT WAS HAPPENING FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW.
>> Tucker: THEY WANT TO DO ALL
KINDS OF THINGS, PUSHING THEM
BACK IN THE JUSTICE OF THE LAW,
A CIVIL RIGHTS DIVISION WHOSE
WHOLE PURPOSE IS TO PREVENT
DISCRIMINATION IN THE WORKPLACE,
HAVE THEY SAID ANYTHING ABOUT
THIS?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT, WE FILED A
COMPLAINT WITH THE EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY DIVISION
WHICH IS THE ADMINISTRATIVE ARM
OF THE GOVERNMENT THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO BE HANDLING STUFF
LIKE THIS AND GO AFTER COMPANIES
LIKE AMERICAN EXPRESS, LIKE
THESE COMPANIES, LIKE UBER AND
CHASE AND THE AS OTHER COMPANIES
THAT ARE INSTIGATING THESE
POLICIES, BUT THEY JUST DON'T
ENFORCE IT, BECAUSE IT IS DONE
IN THE NAME OF "SOCIAL JUSTICE."
AND THEY THINK IT IS DENYING
DISCRIMINATION, WHICH THE WAY
JUSTICE SCALIA SAID IT IS THE
CASE.
>> Tucker: RACISM IS ALWAYS
WRONG NO MATTER WHO IS BEING
HURT BY IT AND IT IS AS WRONG IN
THIS CASE